[Musique]
soit baratte pas en gagnant merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france les
nouvelles continues contamination donc
un parmi les plus importantes d'europe
qui approchent leur niveau de la
violence va de l'hiver dernier comment
vous en tout cas vous vous l'expliquer
à la
personne très européenne habitants est
revenu je ressens et de l'embarras
taux de contamination est parmi les plus
hauts du nuage et c'est vraiment une
honte pour une relation aussi riche
aussi intelligente que la nôtre nous ne
quitterons jamais nous ne traitons pas
le problème qu'on a c'est vraiment
embarrassant et c'est là que nous en
trouvons quand vous dites nous ne
traitons pas le problème correctement je
reviens donc à ma question c'est parce
que ont donc les politiques peut-être ne
le traite pas correctement qu'il ya
cette multiplication des propagations
expliqué nous
propose et
je pense qu'elles sont certainement les
politiques qui
échappe aux manettes infectious diseases
l'extase et nous pouvons gérer la
situation la fiction est encore une
trace en réduisant le contact est
fascinant utilisant tous les
imposants et le port du masque quand il
met en place des mesures de ventilation
dans les yeux
par exemple
les politiques ont décelé cela ne serait
pas nécessaire et nous voyons maintenant
les conséquences aujourd'hui clairement
les scientifiques demandent davantage de
fermeté aux autorités c'est bien cela ce
n'est qu'à ce prix là que vous vous en
sortirez
vous amuser et 2020 dernière chute alors
qu'il faudrait mettre en place tous les
jours de promotions maintenant excuses
attendues proches
des préoccupations des précautions à
l'avenir à vue de l'hiver mais devons
également nous assurer que les écoles
contre le corps navires us et contre la
grippe et le problème là s'agissant de
la vaccination c'est enfin c'est que
c'est qu'elle ralentit nous devons
vacciner les adultes prennent pas la
britpop et cela doit s'ajouter également
à toutes les autres mesures mentionnées
le port du masque de bonne qualité c'est
toujours des masques
les nouveaux variants sont plus je
compte à gland donc ce sont des mesures
simples qu'il faut appliquer brabant
kenyan ne vous entends pas parler de la
vaccination pourtant le royaume uni a
été l'un des meilleurs au monde sur ce
point la campagne a été lancée à ses
taux alors justement ceci explique
peut-être cela c'était trop tôt il ya
peu d'immunité comment on explique
justement ce regard alors que la
vaccination elle est plutôt un succès
chez vous
so
d'immunisation de vaccinations voyez
bruit a commencé tôt et a bien marché
que nous les pays de l'union appelle
nous on rate arrêt et nous ont même de
passer
ce qui n'arrive peut-être et c'est
intéressant nous le suivrons de très
près
c'est que peut-être après environ six
mois ou l'immunité chez les personnes
vulnérables c'est-à-dire les personnes
âgées les personnes qui ont des comores
debout c'est donc l'immunité commença à
diminuer lentement
et dans une situation ils sont
confrontés à un nombre de virus
important la contamination reprend car
les mieux et n'a duré qu'environ six
mois on pourrait peut-être défendre
cette thèse pour ces personnes en
particulier et nous recommandons donc tu
es dose de rappel pour ces personnes ok
dans troisième dose recommandée en tout
cas pour l'autre scientifique que vous
êtes si j'ai bien compris au royaume uni
également on a parlé tout à l'heure de
ce nouveau variant qu'est ce qu'on sait
de lui précisément qui est apparue donc
au royaume uni
la variante est à plus ou moins
2 c'est un petit changement dans l'aspi
q la force publique apparemment cela
pourrait être une variante 10% plus
contaminante que le variant delta muse
et la bonne nouvelle c'est que les eaux
de nommage des is cause il ne pèse pas
des choses plus graves que la maladie
est l'autre bonne nouvelle pour les
besoins by par ses écrits mais ne rompt
pas inefficace la vaccination
nous nous trouvons face à un nouveau
variant d'un thé
nous les surveillons de près un fait
mais il n'est pas inhabituel il n'est
pas extraordinaire pour le moment en
tout cas avec les informations dont nous
disposons une dernière petite question
baraban kenya on en parlait on débute ce
journal l'assemblée qui veut voter
aujourd'hui en france qui votent en tout
cas sur la prolongation de ce pass
sanitaires pour accéder à tous les
endroits de loisirs au cinéma au
restaurant entre autres qu'en est il
chez vous au royaume uni de ce pass
sanitaire est ce que c'est une curiosité
française on sait la même chose chez
vous
nous n'avons pas mis en place de
passeports vaccinale et elle nous
n'envisageons pas cette solution pour le
moment
je pense personnellement qu'un passeport
faxé man u n'est pas nécessaire les cas
aux yeux car il ne dit qu'une seule
chose est mieux de rudy que la personne
non est immunisée mais ne me dit pas si
la personne est contaminée aux
contaminantes
se rappeler que même s'ils ont été
seulement vaccinés les ré toujours que
si la tâche trappe et leur maladie et de
la transmettre donc ma question est la
suivante quel est l'objectif de ce
passeport vaccinale apparaît bien sûr
d'eux de montrer que l'on est bien
vaccinés merci beaucoup baratta pour
gagner d'avoir été avec moi en direct
sur rt france soir